renick lambie was hit and killed back in
november while riding home
on his motorized scooter it happened on
abel's lane right near lake mead and
land
sasha loftis spoke with renick's wife
and son and she joins us now live to
share their message
in a story you'll only see on 8 news now
sasha
denise and brian this is the exact spot
where renick lambie
lost his life back in november now you
can see his family has created this
memorial for him
but they tell me they can't truly honor
him until they found out find out who
did this
someone you know took my husband away
from me
and you know it's hard for me every
single day 76 days ago
renek lambie's life was stolen in an
instant it's been pretty difficult we
have our good days we have our bad days
his wife and son have spent every moment
since
searching for answers i am constantly
thinking
and trying to figure out you know like
who did this to him
the 61 year old was hit and killed here
along abel's lane on november 12.
they did not see him why couldn't you
stop the driver took off
and clues since then have been scarce
until metro police released
this surveillance photo on wednesday of
the white suv
involved in the crash every little piece
is
a moving piece every bit of progress is
good progress
it's a major piece of the puzzle so the
lambies are counting on the community
please come forward and help us to
you know resolve this any tip no matter
how small
could mean closure for them and the
world is dark
and justice for this man they will never
forget and i just need you know to see a
face
you know to the crime
now back out here live the white suv you
saw that was involved in this crash
would have front end damage if you know
anything please call metro police or
crime stoppers
the lambey family is also working to
raise money for a private investigator
to help
figure out this case to solve it if
you'd like to help we have a link on our
website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now